you've done two albums at least with
Linda Perry who's a great songwriter
great collaborator with you and that
story drives me nuts that you heard the
song beautiful I'm beautiful in every
single way which is it's a it's a
brilliant song it's one of my favorite
songs yep and you said to Linda Perry
who you were working with
I want that song That Song speaks to me
I want to sing it I could picture you
singing that song beautifully
and really just connecting with that
song
Linda says to you I don't hear you on
that I gave this song to Christina
Aguilera it was her biggest hit you know
one great thing about Linda is she will
pull
Perfection out of you and she did that
with Christina she did that that song
ended up where it was supposed to be
Christina sounded
incredible on that song Because Linda
will tell you
[__] your stupid vibrato it's what she
used to say to me all the time because I
I sank Phantom of the Opera and Les Mis
she's like no no
I want to know how you feel I want to
know what hurts here's the microphone
and I'm like
and I wrote eventually with her about my
managers that had completely screwed me
over I didn't even know I had that in me
Linda knew I had that in me and she did
that with Christina with that song that
song was it it found its home
but you know Linda and I's relationship
was very very complicated very
complicated I she always said I burst
her bubble and she was so much happier
when she was left alone
and that she never wanted any of this
and so when I found her it was because
it was because of bigger better faster
more it was because of songs like
drifting I used to trip on acid at 12
and 13 years old and sing out of the
attic drifting at the top of my lungs
until the cops were called because her
voice I could feel myself in her and it
was the first time that I could feel
that outside of Janice Joplin and when
you find that in someone
that's why people become fans
and crazy fans because that person knows
them that person knows their pain and
you have to tell them that and that I
had to tell into that and that's why I
went and found her and I wouldn't give
up and so when I was working with her I
felt betrayed when she went on to work
with everybody else
because then she became the pop hit
maker and I was like no our that was I
thought what we had was special and that
was my and everyone was like why the
[__] are you looking for Linda Perry and
I was like you don't understand you
don't understand
that woman well saved my life and she's
so talented and she just went on to be
all these things and it that was the
part that heard it had nothing to do
with Christina it had to do with all of
it